- Oh my God.
- Oh.
- Oh, that's tough.
- Wild boar! Well, I hope it doesn't taste
boar-ing.
- OK.
- Lot of pepper.
- I don't like that.
- It looks like mummified fingers.
- It totally looks like a finger.
- This tastes more like pig.
- That's funny that you say that
'cause I think this tastes more like sh**.
- It's good. I like this one.
- It's like thick and juicy.
- It's like dementoring
my mouth right now.
- Ostrich!
- Right away, it smells like dog treats.
- Well, this is great.
- Awfully chewy.
- I would stop at like a shady 7-11
and pick up some ostrich any day.
- Ya know what this tastes like?
- Hmm?
- A leather belt.
- It's a good chew though.
It's something you could continue.
It's like gum. It's meat gum.
- Ooh, I don't like it!
- Ooh.
- I don't like it!
- (growling) Alligator.
- This one looks like
you need to put chapstik on it
'cause it's so dry.
- This is Groot from
Guardians of the Galaxy.
- That looks inviting. Let's try it.
- Uhh.
- Ooh, it's tough
and dry.
- Maybe this is alligator bones.
- Maybe you just shouldn't
make jerky out of alligator.
Spent so much time thinkin' if ya could,
you didn't stop to think if you should.
- I would never put this in my mouth
and be like, "Oh, that's alligator."
- That's what she said.
I just, I don't know.
- How would she say that?
- This is Alpaca!
- Alpaca's are my favorite.
- This does smell better.
It smells more, like, beefy.
- Look at this face!
Why would you make us eat this?
This one looks a little bit like you.
It really does look like you!
- Ooh, it's not as tough.
- It tastes like something
I'd order at Applebee's.
- Once you get down to
the core of it, it's good.
But, you gotta get through
that mean exterior.
It's like Shrek.
- It's a little more peppery too.
- Mmhmm. Has a little bit
of a zing to it, ya know?
- It's like the alpaca just kicked you.
- Mmhmm.
- Tibetan yak.
- Huh.
- Yak?
- Yak.
- It smells like someone who doesn't,
like, wash their hands
after going to the bathroom.
- This one looks like
it's, like, scorpion meat.
- Uh oh.
- OK, now there's trouble in river city.
- Mmm!
- Ooh!
- I think this one's the best one.
- I kinda like this one.
- Good mouth feel, mouth feel,
people throw that word around.
- Good mouth feel.
- As far as like, tibetan yaks go,
- Mmhmm.
- This is probably the best
thing that could come from it.
- I think I have TMJ now.
- TMJ? Too much jerky?
Is that what that is?
- TMJ dude, too much jerky.